she just sold three of her cows for the
equivalent of over 1 000 euros
she's a single mother and the mobile
cattle auctions organized by
environmental and rural solutions are a
godsend
these auctions are very good for us and
very vital for us because we don't hire
transport
to take our stock to the site for
selling
they come to us and some sometimes you
do negotiate the price if you are not
satisfied
in the past small holders in south
africa's grasslands
could only buy from and sell to their
neighbors the big cattle auctions were
held much too far away
for many around here the mobile auctions
have been the only source of income
during the pandemic
people are organized mostly in grazing
associations
and we offer the auctions as one of the
incentives to belong to the association
you get a
far reduced rate um but people also want
to make cash from their cattle
uh they're a source of the bank they're
the cash cow they're the local economy
they're the local
trading widgets so people people love
coming to these auctions
the environmental and rural solutions or
ers
organization launched the auctions in
2014.
since then 3800 cattle have gone under
the hammer
for a total of 1.7 million euros that's
benefited more than 500 families
the cattle bred here on the grasslands
are renowned for their excellent quality
we commercial farmers and it's an
opportunity for us and for them
to get their cattle sold and and for us
to buy
good cattle and and and to make some
money
environmental scientist nikki macleod
and soil scientist le palesa cicimatela
founded ers 20 years ago
the cattle auctions are just one part of
a wider scheme
to promote sustainable practices in
rural areas
much of the grasslands has been badly
degraded
the fragile ecosystem has been
jeopardized by overgrazing and
mismanagement
[Music]
the grasslands cover 10 percent of south
africa but supply
60 percent of the drought-stricken
countries water needs
against a backdrop of global warming and
climate change
problems such as overgrazing soil
erosion and water security
have become more urgent than ever so
keeping this
beautiful grassland intact as a water
absorber it's basically the skin on the
ground
the skin on the earth keeping this grass
intact is so important for replenishing
our water source areas
and we are also near the headwaters of
the
great um zumbubu river which is one of a
very few still free-flowing rivers
in south africa supplying water to over
1 million people from these mountains
these are mountains around us all the
way to the
indian ocean so it's a very important
landscape not just for us that live
near the hot waters but everybody that
is along that
river system the greater the
biodiversity
the healthier the soil this guy you'll
find him working from school
robust grass cover helps prevent water
from evaporating
and protects against erosion soil queen
i'm not there oh this is this is but
tackling the issue of overgrazing in a
region that depends on livestock farming
is a challenge
one solution involves reviving an
age-old herding tradition
it started a long time ago with our
forefathers
the way they used to do it was to pile
up some stones and paint them
that way the community knew which side
was fallow and which side was for
grazing
started a long time ago but then it got
lost
so each year a different part of the
pasture land would be left
fallow this traditional system of land
rotation had been used for a very long
time
but as more and more people left the
area to find work in the cities
the practice died out a lot of
the younger people didn't understand it
but
if they talked to the elders of the
community then
it was easier to have the system
more accepted the other challenge that
we have
that is major around here is livestock
theft
here in the grasslands 47 of young
people are
unemployed and crime rates are soaring
but ers has found a solution to that
problem as well
in the village of sheep are being
tattooed
so it's clear who they belong to that
makes stealing them pointless
the branding is done by eco champs young
people
trained by the ers team as veterinary
paramedics
they work by themselves distributing
medicine and vaccinating livestock on
remote farms
[Music]
it's a very successful project
i used to have 12 cattle
five sheep but now due to this
association
helping us with the vaccination and
other medicines
i i'm having now 30 a la
la la la sheep i'm having 20 cattle
due to this le pasella cici matella and
nicki macleod
have convinced many people here in
eastern cape province
that living in harmony with nature
benefits them too
and helps secure their livelihoods
they're now keen to protect resources
and conserve biodiversity
in the unique landscape of the
grasslands
so actually all our work is about grass
really healthy grassland better water
absorption
and soil moisture more productive
rangelands
happy fat cattle happy healthy people
it's all about the grass more money at
the market
if you sell the kettle yeah and that we
love our kettle it's not just about
the cash it's about the cows too
environmental protection and sustainable
development
even after two decades the two are as
committed as ever